come on here they are both of them ready
and here comes mu1 levon with the white
pieces and a sicilian defense this is
exciting already um we very rarely see
the main lines of the sicilian at the
top level these days because it is so
complex and is so risky for both sides
and level ironian he doesn't play the
open sicilian white bishop just
developing to the c4 square means that
we see a quieter
start to the game so this is very
reminiscent of the italian opening the
spanish opening uh as we saw in the last
game maneuvering is the name of the game
and both sides of castled levon just
bringing his knight out now
and i think levon just wants to take his
young opponent out of opening theory
eric i see he's one of the best prepared
players i've
maybe ever seen especially for an 18
year old um i've played him a few times
in blitz and i very rarely survived the
opening against him really he's such a
cure for his age in the opening mature
for his age but also i don't know how
he's crammed kind of so much opening
knowledge into just 18 years of life
yeah i mean he knows more about the
opening
now at 18 than i do and i'm quite a lot
older than him so um yeah he's very
impressive in the early stages of the
game arigaisi and just to add to the
story a little bit
i mean we see our yeezy playing very
quickly but levon aronian actually had
this opening once before
against anton korobov a very strong
ground master just recently in may and
there levon aronian beat anton korobov
but here we do see that eric gaici has
come up with an improvement uh in that
game instead of developing the light
square bishop um
korobov actually moved his rook one
square
okay so you think maybe arigati was
aware of that game
just by the speed
speed just just by the fact that you
know look at him he was playing all
these moves our tempo
and uh well
lavon stepped back and suddenly
okay
this this move has been played before
just twice i have to say
and now it's maneuvering as you
mentioned the knight has moved to the f1
square and it will probably head towards
the third rank not quite sure which
square yet but my opinion about this
position is that it's a slow burner
white will try to aim to get a pawn
center by pushing d3 pawn one square
forward
and then just to try to sit on that
space
yeah and uh i must say
eric i see he's one of the few players
as well who
blitzes out their opening preparation as
quickly as they can
there are different strategies to this
different kind of schools of thought
when i know exactly what i'm going to do
in the opening sometimes i pause here
and there just make my opponent kind of
think that i don't really know what's
going on lull them into a false sense of
security and then when they fall into my
trap then suddenly bang bang bang the
moves come thick and fast but eric i see
he doesn't care he wants to let his
opponents know that he knows everything
the moves come thick and fast and
imagine we're already a move 13 both
players have more time than they started
with
especially for such a rare opening to be
this well prepared is uh yeah it's
it shows that these guys are very hard
workers yeah definitely it's a the
approach that you mentioned about trying
to trick in your opponent that was the
kind of approach that i was taught uh
from the 80s 90s and i just wonder
whether it's a generational thing
because of course uh arjun over he's
just uh was born in 2003. so
and i was just thinking you know maybe
this is the style of the youngsters now
you know just uh you intimidate them
with your speed rather than try to set
that trap yeah maybe it's a cultural
thing as well a lot of the top indian
players
especially the younger ones adiban does
the same as arigaisi when i play adiban
it's bang bang bang 25 moves on the
board he doesn't even pause for thought
he's memorized at all and
it's the same with a couple of other
young players nihal sarin and
okay black's last queen move just
sidestepping this position is full of
tension still no trades and it's already
moved 14
and ivanka you mentioned the slow burner
this one it will liven up at some point
it's guaranteed to liven up because
there are so many pieces still on the
board but at the moment it's just about
maneuvering and it's very tense i don't
think anyone really wants to touch pawns
on the queen side at the moment nobody
really wants to touch pawns on the
center you could maybe uh make an
argument for aronian pushing white's
deep one forward one square but if you
don't want to touch these pawns what
else to do you have to maneuver pieces
i'm expecting levon auronian here to
move the white queen i'm just not sure
which square once the white queen moves
the white rooks are connected that marks
the kind of key stage of the middle game
beginning
and
white will have completed development
once the white queen steps forward yeah
i do like that queen stepping forward
but i also was reminded of that
simon williams who we really miss he
will be joining us soon yeah well not
not today but uh later on
during the tournament um
well he kind of says when in doubt fish
harry
and the only reason i'm going to say
this because i'm not really a staunch
harry fan i have to say don't tell simon
i'm only saying this because simon's not
here
but i'm only saying that because the
queen actually is offside
so this is like my little kind of
pattern you know queen is offside
far away from the king no connection
that is a kind of a sign to me that i
can start some operations
looking towards my enemy king okay
instead we see trade oh
just to show you right here ivanka
pushing this pawn forward to try and act
as a battering ram would have been very
interesting but you don't like this one
instead of pushing this pawn exchanging
no because
i mean i i'm looking at the the pieces
that white has there on the left not
that many this is where black is
strongest on so you know we have that
golden rule and chess rules are there to
be broken i acknowledge but
don't touch uh pawns don't open lines on
the side that you're weakest and black
is the one actually who holds the key to
the left side the queen side black is
the one who can push this pawn forward
open up lines black and push this pawn
forward try to open up a line for the
black queen
so your anchor is completely right black
is the one with more space on this side
because these two pawns are very strong
and also
this is an open file but who does it
benefit probably black
because black after a rook trade here
will be ready to replace his rook with
the other rook and
at the very least for black here you
just exchange pieces and you're
completely fine i'm very surprised that
eric geisi actually thought about this
pawn capture that shows the difference
in generations i am told always capture
with pawns towards the center uh but the
younger players sometimes they do
consider breaking the rules maybe he was
thinking of taking this pawn with his
queen but uh after an exchange here i
mentioned this open file
erroneous says you have it take the open
file i don't care and uh rook takes rook
i think if eric icee takes back with his
rook maybe we'll see ivanka's idea of
pushing this pawn forward pushing it
towards the black king or the maybe
classical approach the aronian approach
because you've also called him mr center
in the past would be to establish a
strong center and these two white pawns
now would be decently placed controlling
a lot of squares
and uh i think this must be aronian's
idea um we could see another pawn
exchange but still white has this strong
duo
and
while these pawns exist it's gonna be
hard for black to break out i'm
especially looking at the black bishops
and they are not happy pieces at all
they're completely blocked in compared
to the white minor pieces
yeah
and uh yeah well well aronian had
pre-moved there and uh instead of rook
takes uh every guys he took with his
queen occupying the open fire with his
queen now and jumping forward with the
pawn
at least now after this pawn exchange i
regret his rook is maybe on a semi-open
file for example the black knight can
come attack this bishop or maybe even
jump into the white half of the board
next move
so still roughly in the balance this
position but white does have central
space and iranian likes that all right
well um levon we know will be on the
american team for the olympiad starting
in august or is it starting late july
started late july late july
uh he's going to be the top player on
that american team live on ironian but
arjun ergaise will he play yes he's also
in the
india have three teams so he will be on
the first team i don't they haven't
announced board order right yeah the
order of the players could be changed i
think up until a couple of days before
the event starts but eric icee will play
for the top team um he'll be by far the
youngest on the top team actually um
india's second team is packed full of
the youngsters wow full of teenagers
which is very very exciting for them
but uh yeah we should mention america by
far the favorites in that event and
aronian maybe he'll be the missing
ingredient that will help them uh to
another olympiad victory yeah india
actually have um
some incredible teams on both uh both
the men's olympiad and the and the
women's olympiad actually i should say
open olympia yeah yeah and women's
olympiad india is actually ranked number
one
i that came as a surprise to me there
because i i was asked about india's
chances i was like yeah maybe they have
an outside chance of winning and then
the pairings came sorry the rankings
came out and i was like oh they're top
team in quite right now who would you
have you would have uh who would you
have i was thinking georgia ah georgia
ukraine they have very strong because
china won't be
won't be playing and also russia for
obvious reasons i'm not playing yeah so
i mean china and russia have been the
dominant forces right
in okay open and women's sections in
olympiads over the years but
it's really opened up the field in the
open now the u.s massive favorites
but in the women's i'm not sure it's
really hard to say so many top teams
definitely and they said more teams than
ever actually are going to go and play
in the olympiad oh i bet the atmosphere
will be fantastic again chennai
i'm so you i'm just gonna sit and relax
and watch you guys and we're i'm gonna
root for england us
yeah who needs norway let's go england
to support magnus carlsen will also play
correct actually they're
yeah everyone was surprised norway
ranked fourth in the seedings oh really
yeah traditionally
okay partly because magnus hasn't been
playing most recent olympiads but
traditionally they haven't been among
the favorites but this time there's a
bit of pressure maybe on norway
and uh yeah i mean if magnus wins half
of his games or most of his games then
they've got a great chance oh and well
arientari as well playing in this
tournament will play for the norwegian
team olympiad that must be a lot of a
lot of fun but perhaps also a lot of
pressure playing for your country on a
team
do you enjoy it or
do you dread it
i love olympiads it's always the
highlight for me um
you mentioned a lot of fun yeah it's
nice to see friends uh for example i'll
be seeing some people that i haven't
seen for years due to the pandemic oh
yeah
from all around the world from
new zealand from africa asia all over
the world
but that's the fun side but yeah it's
also it feels special to win a medal for
your team or an individual medal when
there's everyone there yeah when there's
so many countries competing and ivanka
this last move is going to make you
happy he will be happy you know he's
done what i love best you know he's
taking the center with the pawns love
that and then for bonus points he also
pushes harry
something that i was advocating a few
moves ago but i i like that i like it
because you know
the queen is offside she's uh pointing
at a nice open line but not doing much
and uh why not do the modern strategy of
pushing a rook pawn as far up the board
as it can go
yep um i must say i would never play
this move but that's not because it's
bad it's uh it's just a certain type of
player certain type of style
and here are guys
does have a decision to make you have no
real targets as black so you have to
break out you have to gain space
especially for those two black bishops
and i i think the wrong approach here
for arigaisi
one which i might make
the typical mistake that i would make a
lot of players would make is to panic
and actually react to white's last pawn
move for example by pushing a pawn in
front of the black king or uh by going
too defensive i think arrogance he needs
to react to
kind of an attack on the wing with
some kind of counter play in the center
so i think eric i see here is completely
fine but he has to be
just calm energetic i think it's time
maybe to push this pawn forward and you
block out this bishop which is a bonus i
don't think white wants to exchange off
any pawns in the center white wants to
attack so pushing forward and now at
least arigaisi could establish a knight
in the center of the board and uh at
least this would make some sense of the
black queen in the corner as hivanka
mentioned it is a bit
misplaced it doesn't have too much
influence on the rest of the board the
rest of the game but indirectly here it
would defend this black knight so for
example after a trade then okay black
has a bit of an odd pawn structure but
the queen defends the pawn um
if i can get my arrows correct queen
defends the pawn and black now has for
example threats like a knight jump into
the white camp
um so i think this is what eryge needs
to do um in this position of course i
that we wouldn't see uh ironian trade
off these nights i don't think he'll
touch this piece he'll just play around
it maybe instead aronian will go forward
with his pawn trying to push it as far
down the board as possible but at least
erigasi gained some space and
i was saying don't touch pawns don't
react to white's pawn push but he has
pushed a pawn
and this is something that you mentioned
earlier your anchor don't touch pawns on
the side where you're weaker and
oh i don't know this pawn push it looks
so counterintuitive because at some
point you could imagine white's queen
stepping forward
and suddenly a sacrifice happening on
this square
if black say okay there are better moves
of course but if black just makes a
nothing move defends the knight uh to a
safe square then suddenly
this looks super scary for black the
white queen just
scarily close to the king
it looks terrifying doesn't it
especially because the knights are going
to also join her majesty into the
operation um
yeah
it's
but it's i have to say is it a very it
was a very natural reaction i think
i think i think it takes like ice
what do they say
ice water ice water in the veins to kind
of react so calmly go okay well you're
not doing anything there i'll just
do carry on with my business in the
center um but okay
we see levon push forward with harry i
don't understand any of these no i don't
that one i don't understand either
because um
yeah
yeah this pawn push it just puts upon
now you've kind of provoked a weakness
you've already forced black's pawn
forward this is the whole point of your
advance but now with white's last pawn
push putting the pawn on the h5 square
this pawn is defended yes but you've
tied down your knight defending it for
the near future and it's not as if
you're going to make any pawn breaks you
can't open up lines with this pawn
anymore so you've kind of just blocked
things up
and you've tied down one of your own
pieces
maybe he was reluctant to move the queen
because of some very specific concrete
tactical reasons but
it just feels like both sides are
waiting they're just kind of
not wanting to commit that pawn
structure it feels like white doesn't
want to step forward with these pawns
because
why touch them they're nice uh they
control all the central squares already
but it feels like eric geise is too
scared to touch these pawns as well
because he's scared he would leave
weaknesses if he pushes them forward but
uh you can't just wait forever and okay
every guys he steps back with his bishop
this confirms my theory that he doesn't
really know what to do or doesn't want
to commit um that is one good uh one
good thing behind this bishop retreat
now indirectly you defend this pawn so
there won't be any sacrifices near your
king but
it's very much a waiting game it feels
like both players
if not nervous then at least they're
reluctant to make a big
push forward
and uh yeah it looks like they're just
treading water at the moment just
surviving and not really
wanting to be the first one to break the
ice yeah i have to say i'm i really am
not a big fan of white pushing the pawn
all the way to the fifth row primarily
because i i kind of wanted the knight
that i actually now sitting on g3
doesn't have a roll i mean that could
have gone to that square instead the
pawn is sitting pretty and it's not like
the light square bishop the white house
can even think about getting into the
game and relocating itself to a better
diagonal because i'm sorry that is stuck
there on that square defending okay
finally he um actually finally is the
wrong word
he steps forward with a queen one square
yeah with a threat with a threat yes the
knight is under attack
um
now is is it the chance to step forward
in the center i think he pretty much has
too right if if uh not compulsory then
uh it would at least be the most
consistent again we have to jump in
because critical moment now for eric icy
if he's too scared to touch these pawns
then he might live to regret it because
uh remember this knight is attacked and
if it retreats that's only a step in the
wrong direction you're retreating back
into your own half you've lost a lot of
time with that piece why do that
but uh in order to defend this knight
you have to push your ball forward
unleashing the bishop to defend it but
you do meanwhile allow white to gain
some space and
yeah the knight can jump in attacking
the white queen remember this is a
knight that white doesn't want to
capture it doesn't want to trade off but
for example if the queen sidesteps the
key is whether black's knight can
survive
in the center
if we ever see a night trade the white
bishop or pawn could even recapture
i'm slightly attracted to taking back
the pawn just because now the white pawn
can step forward and break down the
black king position
but meanwhile what are black's pieces
doing this black bishop is bad this
bishop is passive and he does step back
with his knight instead you don't like
this one you're very good no i i don't
like it i i much prefer the more active
option of pushing the pawn forward in
the center here i mean the first worry
that i would be
concerned about for for
for black is what happens if white just
pushes forward with the d pawn and tries
to secure some squares yeah it's very
tempting right but i guess
after a porn exchange the question is if
you do take back maybe the black knight
can come to the edge of the board
attacking your bishop
maybe jumping into this square next
yeah the night is dancing but at least
it's the decent squares
yeah that is true so uh okay
but still you know white's pieces get
very active and okay this is also a very
nice move actually just stepping back
with the bishop
i say it's a very nice move but i'm
going to backtrack a little bit because
it does has the con does have the
consequence of the black queen being
allowed to step forward
all the way to the second row
and if that's going to work
then okay maybe eric is doing very well
yeah it's all about whether black's
counter play here with the black queen
for example on the queen side
is that quick enough because there will
be threats for example white's pawn
stepping forward attacking the black
knight kicking away a defender of the
black king if that knight moves maybe
we'll see a porn trade first but if the
black knight moves then suddenly white
could line up some really nasty
checkmating ideas along this diagonal
trying to sneak in to trap the black
king for example knight takes bishop now
would be met by a nasty checkmate this
is a typical pattern if you line up your
white queen with the light squared
bishop sneaking in towards the black
king
so very direct threats maybe very
specific ideas but um
is aronia going to be quick enough with
his pawn
and i like this move from eric i see
offering a coin exchange saying okay
you've got some ideas or at least some
outlines of a checkmating attack so
let's get the queens off the board
and the black queen defended by its
knight
what do you think ivanka queen trade or
no queen trade uh no queen trade but uh
then again
i do quite like that queen uh queen move
by aragus it's good defensive strategy
but it makes no sense for white to trade
off queens because you know white's
position is just building itself up to
attack the king and you need the queen
you need that to be there on sitting
preferably on the d3 square i know
that's actually not possible now
but uh
yeah the problem is you want your queen
and bishop lined up on this diagonal but
as ivanka said it's not possible right
now it walks into a nasty night fork
so it's all about timing and right now
aronian has to decide what to do with
his queen he steps it back to its
starting square
that is not ideal either maybe now the
black knight will come back we're doing
a little dance like the knights the
bishops the knight steps forward the
bishop steps back the knight steps back
the bishop steps forward
yeah it's really really tense right now
and both sides have kind of
maneuvered their furniture and uh i mean
who's benefited from that actually it
seems to me that maybe black
is the one valuation bar thinks black
yeah i don't know so sure but yeah
it's all about concrete variations right
i mean i feel that if black can trade
off queens black is probably doing
really well
if
white can keep the queens on and somehow
start pushing black pieces back
then uh okay he will be doing very well
so oh everything in the balance at the
minute the next few moves are going to
be absolutely critical
and
talking about critical
era guys he just accelerates the play he
pushes the pawn forward attacks the
bishop and lavon is cool he's like step
step my bishop back attack your queen
yeah we should mention there was a
really nice tactical point ergaici it
looks like he just sacrificed a pawn by
pushing this pawn forward it looks like
he's just blundered a pawn away this
pawn is after all attacked three times
by white it's only defended twice but
after a series of captures this is why
the top players they're so good they
calculate so quickly after takes
black takes back white takes back black
captures after all of this suddenly
there's a tactic in the air there's a
really nice trick rook takes bishop wins
a piece because the white queen is
overworked she has to defend the rook
next to her so if she moves away and
captures this black rook then whoops the
white rook drops this is check and black
has won a piece in the process
so
i mean just
i've gotta applaud both players there
firstly eric geissy for seeing a long
long tactic like that what is it like
five six moves in advance but uh also
aronian he didn't blink he instantly
reacted he didn't blunder like that and
he stepped back with his bishop
attacking the black queen and now it's
ivanka's idea of the queen jumping in
it's uh yeah i mean all of these hidden
little traps they exist all the time in
chess and it's just about spotting them
yeah
definitely and the position is really
sharpening up because do you think uh
lavon is gonna actually gonna try to
defend this pawn that's under attack uh
no he closes the position down
i'm
not sure about that
and i'm a big fan of pushing pawns so
you won't often hear me say that about a
pawn push
so why are you not a big fan of that one
ivanka because it closes down the light
square bishop
and
i had dreams that that bishop would be
going to the b3 square let's start
looking at the black king and now no
it's not happening it's dead
it is dead and uh with the center now
blocked completely locked up
it's unlikely we'll see a direct attack
against either of the kinks especially
not against the black king
if you look at the black knight on the
f6 square that's a great defender of the
black king now and we'll keep it safe
for the foreseeable future
on the plus side i guess with this spawn
push you gain a bit of space with white
you ask black you ask eric gaisey a
really difficult question the black
knight that has just been attacked by
this white pawn where do you go do you
step back if you step back maybe you're
on a bad circuit you're on a passive
square if you step into the center of
the board you offer a pawn exchange but
changing the strike knight exchange
story but changing the pawn structure
it's
he does this eric guys you look at black
structure in the center of the board
those two double black d pawns they are
very ugly it's just about whether eric
is he can keep all his pawns alive using
tactics and he's very good at that he's
very tactical eric icy
but first in order to get rid of the
tactics and all the fun out of the
position aronian offers a queen exchange
in an end game white has the better
structure long term you would think that
white is doing quite well there but
every guys he goes for it
who do you think this will favor no i
think it's going to favor levon and it's
not the double pawns that worry me it's
the bishop sitting on f8 next to the
king that really worries me because look
at it it's
very much very passive and also if i
look to the future it's not going to
have a great role either because it
always has to guard the weak pawn in the
center yeah i'm just very worried that
okay i was going to say that white is
going to win a pawn soon but
yeah i regularly he's going to get
greedy he's going to grab this white h
pawn i highlighted it as a weakness
earlier but look at this the white
knight has jumped in and
it's only a temporary pawn sacrifice by
aronian in order to displace the black
pieces but also one of the black pawns
in the center i'm looking at the black
d4 pawn
that's toast it's going to be captured
and
yeah black's position is in ruins
totally and uh when one pawn falls
another one will also fall and i'm
looking also at the the b5 pawn look at
that all by itself no friends
and uh that's gonna go
and still
black star square bishop yeah these two
are just gonna drop off and uh this is
also a weakness on the d6 square three
weak pawns
as you mentioned this bishop is bad not
only is this bishop bad now but this
bishop is completely stuck on the wrong
side of the board hitting against a
concrete wall it's just hitting against
a stronghold for white and the only
piece that can hope to patch up all the
holes in the black position is the black
knight
but it's going to take a long time
where's this black knight even going is
it going to jump forward this way maybe
right now aronian is just in complete
control he can just take this pawn now
the material balance is back hitting
this one is ivanka mentioned
how do you even defend it if you defend
it with your rook white bishop can come
forward and attack it the white knight
can jump into this beautiful outpost
i mean everything beautiful here about
white structure totally connect four i
know and it's like every single one of
white's pieces could actually improve
themselves and it'll be a fantastic move
um the rook yeah the brook the bishop
both bishops i mean
so much potential in the white position
no it's a dream for lavon ironian and uh
i do think aragasi is probably what we
kind of say positionally lost yeah you
know if lavonne just plays a perfectly
get perfect game
paragusy will have no chance but luckily
it's rapid play
it's rapid chess and the clock play
plays an important factor and of course
psychology yeah yeah lavon he does have
a lot of time left though yeah
he's played uh fast so far i live on
eronion and we know that from when he
had success on the tour earlier it's
been when he's played quite fast right
yeah
and he's played very confidently and i
remember he just didn't
respect any any of his opponents even
magnus carlsen he was playing incredibly
quickly yeah and uh okay
and uh aronian's saying my position is
so good let's trade off rooks
and
well it kind of works as well like i'm
not going to criticize that move
yeah you meant uh you mentioned this
phrase positionally lost and that means
black just has the worst pawn structure
black's pieces are worse so why not
exchange off one of them black's most uh
active pieces the black rook
if you exchange off everything then
black is still left with those pawn
weaknesses later in the game and eric
guys he said no
my rook is the only active piece left
the black rook now going to the open a
file
and aronian meanwhile grabbing pawns
back
it's level material once again but that
black b5 pawn is doomed black's bishops
are terrible black's knight takes at
least two or three moves to get anywhere
decent
i think this one
barring any
big blunders from aronian or barring any
kind of miraculous tricks by eragaisi
this one is only headed in one direction
and that's a white win
yeah
i mean i'm just looking at you know ways
that aragaisi can try to hold the
position i'm going to use the word hold
because i feel that's what he has to do
he has to just put up some resistance
and just frustrate lavon you know just
make another one lash out
because that's the only kind of chance
that he has to rescue this
and uh okay the knight centralizes
itself
and talking of tricks there is one nasty
little trick in the position uh it's
never too late to blunder in chess and
right now aronian he could blunder if he
gets too greedy if he takes his pawn
the fact that aronia is thinking means
he's spotted this by the way but uh if
he takes this pawn it's too hasty it's
impatient because suddenly black's
bishop can capture the white pawn
black's bishop was doing nothing it was
offside and suddenly after
white takes back it looks like white's
won a piece but after this knight check
it's actually a double attack and the
bishop drops off on the next move when
the white king moves
the bishop falls and actually black is
the one
in control suddenly so it's never too
late to blunder but of course aronian he
will spot these things this is why we
always look at checks captures and
threats first of all don't take this
pawn instead aronian moves his bishop
the bishop was the one that was loose
and would have dropped off in that last
variation we just showed so he moves it
to a better square and he's hinting that
he might even capture this black knight
later on you don't want to rush with
that because you give up the dark
squares but uh maybe later he'll take
this night off if he needs to
yeah and uh yeah that avoids the trick
this pawn is long term
gonna drop off anyway so no rush to take
it
no certainly no rush to take that pawn
and uh well again i'm struggling i'm you
know really trying to think of ways that
are guys he can hold this position and
it's tough
yeah it just may be one move at a time
and that's where he kind of makes this
very ugly
move i mean i really don't like it just
look at it i was taught by my father
when i was very young about i think
eight years old you know that this
triangle formation is so weak especially
if it's restrained because
there's so many holes
but okay
sometimes ugly chest is necessary chess
yeah you're right your anchor you
mentioned the word holes look at all
those light squares in the black camp
white knight now can jump
into any square
but
yeah as you mentioned you just got to
survive that's step one when you're
defending difficult positions when
you're really knuckling down grinding
out all the draws from
uh kind of difficult situations you have
to just defend play ugly moves
yeah and again iranian has the question
does he rush does the white knight go
and take the black b5 pawn again i'm not
so sure you should
or do you just take a timeout maybe
improve the white king
somehow sooner or later you've got to
improve this white light squad bishop
sitting at the bottom of the board on b1
that's not a great piece either
yeah
from aronian it's like we said earlier
he's spoiled for choice so many good
options
no direct win as well that can be
frustrating
and he's yeah he still can't take that
pawn as you mentioned so
yeah you don't get frustrated lebron you
just has to
just channel that summer energy i'm just
looking at that painting it's very
colorful
and it kind of it's kind of the thing
that you have
on your walls to put you in a good mood
that's true yeah but you don't want to
put your opponent in a good mood right
because your opponent will be looking at
your webcam no but they might be trying
to work out the detail which you already
know so it's a good strategy but anyway
i'm a big fan of having good vibes good
energy in the house and uh talking about
good vibes good energy whilst levon is
thinking about
what to make a move you know what what
is oh he takes the pawn
yeah oh
no no no no no i was not advocating that
i keep attention
and uh
oh
bart is definitely going towards
volunteering a mysterious decision there
because he's allowed arjun to get active
yeah he might have won a pawn
temporarily live on iranian but he's
given up so much in return suddenly
black is going to get the bishop pair
after black takes off this bishop every
guy is he now just deciding which way to
recapture this bishop he takes with the
d pawn in order to suddenly free up
black's dark square bishop and look at
black star squad bishop it is going to
come to life and
white is a pawn up temporarily but
suddenly this white b2 pawn is under
fire from the black rook the black
bishops combine quite nicely and white
has zero control over the dark squares
that's just hasty that is just
i mentioned the word impatience earlier
and that is the one thing that could
have stopped erroneous winning this game
it might well stop him now
because actually if you think about it
where is white's knight going to come
back to where is its retreat square it's
kind of stuck in no man's land this
white knight
and okay it retreats this way but at the
very least now uh eric i see at some
point we'll be able to grab this pawn
back i'm also wondering whether you want
to take it now allowing white's rook
into the seventh rank this could be a
bit scary um you could actually stop
white's rook coming uh to such an active
square with the move ary guys he's just
played
very nice control and this is why we
love the two bishops both attacking wise
and defensively because suddenly these
bishops control all the entry squares
for the white rook look at this white
rook it wants to enter the black car for
the board but it just can't the bishop
control the bishops control
uh everything pretty much and white's
knight is kind of just sat there nice
and pretty but it's not doing anything
and meanwhile still a threat against
this pawn so
okay eric is he's not out of the woods
yet he's still on the defending side
because he's temporarily won pawn down
but aronian i think he's
blown most of his advantage or at least
his advantage has a different nature now
aronian's advantage three or four moves
ago was permanent it was long term now
veronin's advantage is very temporary
if this pawn drops if this white b2 pawn
drops his advantage is completely wiped
out
so ironian needs to find something now
is now or never yeah i think it was very
impractical to grab that pawn because
yeah like you say you know it might have
been
my being like winning it still might be
really good for him but
in terms of uh human moves well i think
it's now very difficult for him to play
i i can't see a way forward to be honest
with you i don't see
what to do maybe you have to try and get
your rook in somehow but it's really
difficult because this square for
example if it ends up on the a7 square
it would be on a dart square
you're right your bank it's really hard
to see what to do you don't really want
to go
don't want to go passive no yeah
actually i was thinking of stepping the
brook up one square but he very sensibly
goes behind his pawn trying to kind of
propel this pawn forward but now eric is
able to activate the black king and
actually a threat against this knight to
win the pawn back
around defends it and every guy see now
he's going to try and create some
counter play really interesting he steps
this pawn forward now it's just
impossible the problem for white is it's
impossible to activate this pawn you
can't push it two squares forward
because that square is covered by
black's rook and bishop so if you can't
push that pawn forward what else do you
do yeah arigaisi is going to try and
push his pawns now this is the side
where he is stronger
but do you think that arigaisi will even
try to launch active operations if you
just like shuffles is king backwards and
forwards i'm thinking of some world
championship matches where they did this
and okay very important move by eric
icee taking control of the open lines
yeah controlling the a-file just
stopping white i think from controlling
the a-file as well and again problem is
you can't push your pawn forward because
uh or maybe you can but um yeah at the
very least this pawn will get attacked
by the black rook and by the black
bishop and there's a skewer along this
diag along this rank
so
it's just difficult for iranian how does
he improve his position again it's that
type of advantage after this rug move
that could just fizzle out
very very quickly i would have rather
taken that long-term advantage even not
winning a pawn
that he had a few moves ago now he's
a porn up but
the margin for error is so small now
yeah totally
and also you know there is in the air
that always that threat of bishop takes
knight take it into opposite color
bishop end game so uh yeah if the rook's
ever come off it's just a dead draw
right because uh
as ivanka mentions the black bishop will
just take the white knight the light
squad bishop
and opposite colour bishops black wall
blockade on the dark squares easy draw
so levon wants to avoid that because
he's had the advantage for a long time
now yeah but do you think er ergaizi
wants to avoid it as well now do you
think he sees some chances
if aronian continues to think so
right now i'm looking at the clocks as
well eric i see he's been at two two two
and a half minutes for the last 10 15
moves yeah aronian at some point was at
nine ten minutes he's
slowly starting to drop and as a chess
player you always sense the momentum and
eric i see
five ten moves ago he would have been
thinking oh
my position is nearly hopeless i've got
two minutes on the clock
oh life is so hard
but then
suddenly 10 moves later oh actually my
position isn't that bad oh my opponent's
spending a lot of time
life's pretty good yeah yeah that's just
the the workings of a chess player's
mind it's uh
we the momentum especially rapid chess
as well it's drifting it's only is
drifting and it's the flow is all in
eric's favor yeah and the clock is
ticking down and uh yeah it's true levon
has to be careful of uh any activity on
the dark squares and yeah you can just
see by by lavon's body language he's not
happy you know he's
jumping up and down you know he's
fidgeting
and this these to me
as a chess player signal discomfort
yeah and he's a very instinctive player
level iranian okay he pushes the pawn
forward just to stop the black pawns
from marching but look at this the black
rook is getting active cutting off the
white king now the black rooks on a
great rank the second rank but yeah um
aronian he's a very instinctive player
but this is not the type of position
where you can just rely on instinct you
have to be really careful you have to
kind of step pawns forward in a really
sophisticated clever fashion you have to
think calculate a little bit before you
make any uh moves with any of your
pieces and look at white's rook compared
to the black rook white's completely
stuck
white bishop just pointing at its own
pawns
no control over the dark squares
suddenly i'm not sure
who's whose position i prefer
yeah i could really easily see this
going wrong for white yeah here's under
on the clock now levon neronia and he's
been up by
so much for the entire game but he is
now down on the clock yeah
as david mentioned you know the shift
the tide is turning you know before he
had a very easy position to play you
know he could almost make any improving
move and his position was just great
here he has to tread very carefully and
i just love what era guys he's done
cut off the white king and yeah if the
dark square bishop gets active then
maybe
you can even start looking at try and
trade off some rooks or maybe even get
ambitious and push
harry the h pawn yeah we should mention
that we've been talking about white's
past pawns white's b-pawn is a runner it
can run later on
white also has a past deep on it's
blocked right now but black's got a
potential passport uh that h pawn
sitting there very innocently on h6 if
it starts pushing forward
that could well be a game changer and uh
heronian what's he thinking he's really
frozen
well i don't see a natural move for him
as well yeah well he doesn't have too
long on the clock though he
has
just under one and a half minutes it was
interesting commentating with younger
stuff so i have to say because he gives
me what's with your negative reaction
towards the clock and i'm like what do
you mean and he goes you always say just
under just under one and a half minutes
i'm like he goes when you should say he
has just over he should phrase it in
positive terms and i'm like i've never
thought about that
well
we do see a lot of time trouble in the
champions league no doubt about that
games
lost when clocks are under the minute
we've seen that so many times exactly
but to these speed demons they're like
you haven't plenty of time what do you
want about one minute
i can play 100 moves
and okay the king centralizes itself
black's position is just consolidating
itself but still
that pawn age pawn can start moving up
the board and
whoa whoa where's this going i don't
really see the path of this rook irony
just shook his head as well
we should mention that that's really
important uh it gives us a signal about
how he feels about the position but
where's this white rook going is
zig-zagging across up the board to the
third rank
we talk about rook swingers rook lifts
where's this rook swinging across to
it's blocked by its own pawns on the
third rank oh yeah but there's there's
no plan behind it either i mean exactly
i mean what's he he's not threatening to
push the b pawn so if black's rook just
waits for example what is white doing
i'd be so tempted now as arigaisi to go
for the win to start pushing the black h
pawn down the board
i'm not sure he really feels uh kind of
enough potential in his position to try
and win this game so i wouldn't blame
him if he if he doesn't do anything now
a rig i see but
yeah at the very least the black dart
square bishop can come and attack this
white rook
that would be very logical as well he
does that
asking this rook where are you actually
going well one way one square he must
not go to is the dark squared e3 square
because then that would be in the same
diagonal as the king and instead he
steps back with the rook to where it
came from
um okay well if our geissey
wants to signal that he's happy with the
draw he's just going to step back with
the bishop but uh
to be honest why should he yeah so no
reason to the evaluation bar as well for
the first time pretty much in the whole
game but the first time in a long time
at least it's on black side and he's
going for the win yeah
we'd love to see such confidence i mean
these guys are sharks let's face it yeah
they might have been suffering the whole
game they might have been dead lost but
if they sense a win they pounce
yeah it's just uh it's just like magnus
when i was watching the well when i was
commentating on the candidates at some
point i took a break magnus jumped on uh
to the candidates commentary and he was
really critical of napoli's decision not
to press against nakamura and he said be
a shark if you sense a tiny little bit
of weakness in your opponent or if you
sense even if you were losing earlier if
you tend to change your momentum be a
shark smell the blood in the water go
for the win
and uh
okay i'm not sure i like this decision
too much but i like the attitude behind
it every guys he did push the black h
pawn forward we saw an exchange
at least now white has a chance to
activate his rook white's rook is going
to swing across to the g file the square
that's just been evacuated by the white
king and it's going to come up the board
i'm not sure where it's going after that
but uh at least iranian's rook will
finally
find some kind of uh
duty it will find some kind of action
well this is a tense game both players
around the minute on the clock a bunch
of the other games have finished i'm
especially noticing a win for jeffrey
zion against fellow american hans
niemann three points for jeffrey there
and also sam sevillan a win against ji
wen jun a great start for the young
americans and it was a draw between
aryan tary and his boss inies geary they
have been working together but this one
oldest against youngest in the
tournament what will be the result
yeah it's anyone's game right now i
think if you asked me five moves ago
before eric guys he pushed his h-born i
would ascend i would have said dead draw
no chance for either side but suddenly
everything to play for white's rook has
suddenly got very active
blacks h pawn is inching down towards
the white king
i mean i don't really see what white's
last move threatens maybe white's rook
just wants to slide behind the h-pawn
and go and win it
yeah but
oh he can be defended right
yeah
i thought some of them resigned because
i saw the light shift
but that's maybe a sign they're checking
out each other's webcam
to check the tension live on ticking two
one minute on the clock bar is jumping
from side to side yeah this move it's
very clever i like it from a practical
point of view the computer slightly
disagrees but black's bishop now
defending this black h-born is going to
go and park itself on a very active
square
but it has let the white knight out of
the box and white's knight is actually
threatening something really nasty right
now white's knight wants to jump back to
the b7 square to check the black king
the black king is in checking distance
any time your king is near an opponent's
knight you have to look out for night
forks knight checks
the knight dancing around
if you move the black light square
bishop
not to this square if you've moved it in
a another direction you could have
walked into a checkmate in one move so
uh now the knight if it does go to the
left side to give a check it will get
captured yeah
and uh guys he's just too good he says
no i spotted it
very and uh okay still the question to
levon how to handle black's initiative
because black is uh perhaps threatening
to reroute the dark square bishop and
then maybe get super ambitious and walk
the king
towards the center you know forget
material forget past pawns you know he's
just going for one thing yeah maybe
check mating the king yeah ivanka big
moment now is the black king actually
going to make a mad dash for the victory
and yes wow he's going forward he's
running into the position the black king
just trying to get greedy and aronian
meets that with an amazing night move
jumping back sacrificing his knight with
the idea that if the knight is captured
this is a double attack
and what is happening right now aronian
has won a second pawn every geisha says
i don't care the black king is coming
the black king is actually going to try
and move towards these pawns if it can
combine with the black bishop then
actually white's king in the corner
might be a target for example if the
white knight goes in the wrong direction
and checks suddenly i mean for example
here this is going to end up is
as a checkmate simply white's king is
powerless in the corner of the board
black's king's super active so in the
current position right now i think it's
actually time for aronian to find some
really desperate moves i'm not even sure
what he should play maybe he should give
a night check but when the black king
comes forward maybe now he should jump
back with his rook try and trade
something off and he's not got too much
time it's very very scary the king is in
he has pushed this pawn i just gave this
is losing i gave this as an example of
what he shouldn't do now the black
bishop simply goes back and this is
going to end up in some nasty
checkmating ideas
blunder by lavon
the problem is now if you push your pawn
forward one more square attacking this
bishop oh he doesn't
find it but ah look at this on the
computer it did say that this black
bishop move was winning here now the
black king would march forward and this
is inevitable you can actually allow
white to make a new queen but you give
checkmate this is a mating net every
guys he didn't spot this and if we go
back a couple of moves this bishop move
would have been winning he brought his
other bishop in though this is maybe
still decent we see it's uh now forced
iranian to find two moves he finds the
best one level in iranian bringing his
bishop back what's a move that is giving
a way a bishop for free but now after
bishop takes bishop this pawn is running
through to make a new queen it's just
chaos right now
and when the players have
just over 10 seconds on the clock
anything can happen and i think there's
only one move that is bishop takes
bishop
and uh well black has to allow that
queen to be promoted but just look at
this it's crazy white is about to make a
new queen but guys he just doesn't care
if white makes a new queen right now
then the black bishops are going to
combine and this is nasty this king is
still trapped in the corner if you move
across then suddenly another bishop
track and this king will get checkmated
a rooney cannot make a queen three
seconds
oh he needs to he's done it and he's
okay maybe he can
wow what a move by ronin he made a new
queen and here this check he answered it
by throwing his rook in the way
and maybe he'll save the game the whole
idea is if this rook is captured with a
check now the white king can hide safely
because the black bishop giving a check
would allow the bishop to get captured
these players are just so incredible
both at the top of their game and in the
current position if we go back to it
now every guy see he's threatening to
win by moving his rook out the way with
the discover check from the bishop but
aronian needs to give some checks
himself it's time for the white queen to
start checking the black king drop back
to this square with a check there we go
and it should now
is it wow is it is it are you saying it
should be a drawback
maybe black is the winning king the king
is gonna hide yeah look at the part it's
saying a hundred yeah it's saying plus a
hundred the black king is just going to
sneak around to safety and this white
king is going to be the one that dies
let's go back to the players we'll show
this in more detail later because this
is just
this is the play of the day it's just
incredible stuff ronnie's shaking his
head
i said it should be a draw but no harry
geissey four seconds three seconds
aronian has to give a check he does and
now the black king is going to hide
itself away just look at that wow look
at where the black king is hiding in
white's camp next move the black rook is
just going to move out the way
with the discover check white king is
the one that's actually getting mated
and just like that
eric gaici wins it's over the youngest
player in the tournament at 18 years old
arjun ergaizi he beats number